ich habe ende letzten jahres vier
tickets zum abschiedskonzert für meine
tochter gekauft
der gesamtbetrag für die tickets war 158
euro
das konzert wurde abgesagt ich habe
daraufhin 133 euro zurückerstattet
bekommen die 25 euro die ich nicht
zurückerstattet bekommen habe waren laut
eventim system gebühren und
versandkosten
der veranstalter bolt berlin sagt dass
sie mir den kompletten betrag den sie
bekommen hätten zurückerstattet haben
und dass diese 25 eur von eventim
einbehalten worden sind jetzt meine
frage ist es rechtens dass diese
gebühren dieser angeblichen system
gebühren einfach einbehalten werden
danke ihr system gebührend klingt immer
so ein bisschen nebulös herr pauschal es
hat sich ja völlig zurecht und uns
gewandt und kempkens weiß auch schon
wahrscheinlich wohin der hase läuft wie
ist die lage also ein bisschen
umstritten muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
wir haben wir jetzt diese
gutscheinlösung das heißt im moment
bekommen wir nicht unbedingt bargeld
sondern eben den gutschein und diese
gutscheinlösung sieht vor dass ich auch
alles wieder bekomme das heißt auch die
vorverkaufsgebühren die versendung
gebühren und diese ganzen anderen dinge
bekomme ich erstattet so und jetzt haben
wir ja hier einen fall da ist noch bar
zurück erstattet worden worauf ich ja
jetzt gesetzlich im moment noch nicht
einmal anspruch habe
also eigentlich ist dass er ein besserer
fall der betroffene kann sich hier also
erst mal glücklich schätzen dass er das
bargeld bekommen hat und jetzt ist ja
die absage nicht erfolgt weil er
irgendwas schief gegangen ist beim
veranstalter sondern cola bedingt wir
haben also kein verschulden dh der
vertragspartner und das ist der
veranstalter der darf also das behalten
was er schon erbracht hat so geringe
kosten die da angefallen sind
beispielsweise versendung kosten die
durfte er behalten aber diese 25 euro da
sind ja ja das sind ja 15 prozent etwas
von dem was wir gehört haben das
erscheint mir sehr viel zu sein
da meine ich eigentlich dass dieser
abzug zu hoch ist geringere abzüge
versendung okay aber nicht in dieser
größenordnung
vor allem weil wir unter dem begriff
systemkosten natürlich auch irgendwie
alles und nichts fassen kann nämlich an
ja ganz genau das müsste man dann auch
genauer begründen das müsste dann
genauer berechnet werden und vor diesen
berechnungen schaut natürlich jede
konzertveranstalter gesellschaft zurück
weil da müsste man die eigenen die
berechnungen zugrunde legen und die
kalkulation zugrunde legen das geht
natürlich gar nicht macht auch keiner
und deswegen sind da so pauschalierte
abzüge okay aber eben nur in ganz
geringem rahmen und das was wir gehört
haben erscheint mir doch deutlich zu
viel